high performance liquid chromatography
or hplc helps determine the chemical
composition of
unknown mixed samples such as those
containing proteins
that can't be easily vaporized into a
gas
a sample is first passed through a
pressurized column containing a solvent
that separates the samples individual
chemical components
unlike gas chromatography where the
sample is vaporized before being passed
through a column
in hplc the sample stays in liquid form
as the different compounds emerge from
the column their transit times and
relative concentrations are recorded by
a detector
the printed results or chromatogram show
each compound as a peak
representing quantity and exit time by
comparing these peaks to the pattern
shown by known substances
an analyst can often determine the
chemical composition of the
original sample